في موضوع ثاني لديك احلام ايضا الفيل يعود
الى تونس بعد اكثر من عشرين عام ليش وين
كاين بعشرين سنه من تونس اسم هاجر
هو في الحقيقه نعم هو كان الحدث الذي طغى
على الاحداث السياسيه والاقتصاديه بامتياز
قدوم الفيله بيبي الفيله بيبي التي تبرع
على بها رجل اعمال الفرنسي عن طريق صديقه
التونسي وجاءت الى تونس الفيله بيبي التي
يتجهز الاطفال هنا لزيارتها في اقرب وقت
ممكن حالما تكون جاهزه لذلك نذكر انو اخر
فيل كان موجود في تونس هي الفيلا بامبي
التي رحلت للاسف وماتت منذ اكثر من 20 سنه
ومنذ ذلك الحين لم تعد هناك اي فيل في
تونس هذا الحيوان الذي يحبه الاطفال كثيرا
تعود الفيله بيبي الان لكي تحظى باستقبال
جماهيري على ما اظن في الايام القليله
القادمه لتزين حديقه البلفيدير هي اكبر
احدى اكبر الحدائق الحيوانات التي يزورها
الاطفال والعائلات في تونس ونعرف ان هذا
الحيوان محبوب جدا من الكبار ومن الصغار
فاعتقد فانا خدومه سوف يضفي الكثير من
هكذا اعتقادك صحيحه احلام العبد الله
يعيشك شكرا جزيلا وافرحوا صغارا وكبارا في
تونس على قلبي بيبي
شكرا جزيلا
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات